hey there guys do i have an exercise and
a half for you today today we're going
to be talking about the hindu push-up
also called dand and very similar to
another exercise called the dive bomber
so essentially the hindu push-up if
you've not heard of it before it's a
push-up where you're starting in
something akin to a pike push-up
position or even a downward dog and then
you're going to dive down towards the
ground and swoop up at the top this has
so many benefits it's an exercise i
think that everyone should be doing and
yet say a few people do do it why is no
one doing it this is something we need
to put a stop to but never fear the
bioneer is here
but first let me try and sell you on why
you should be doing the hindu push-up
i'll try and convince you of its
benefits this is a single exercise that
can improve your hamstring flexibility
your shoulder strength your core
strength your pecs your triceps even
open up your shoulders and build
coordination it's a fantastic movement
then and because you're getting all this
in one go it means you have to spend
long amounts of time stretching on a mat
somewhere so to begin with you're
starting off in what is essentially a
downward dog position now here there's
no strict requirement to get your heels
flat on the floor to keep your legs nice
and straight however there's no reason
not to aim for that because if you do
then you're getting this fantastic
hamstring stretch this fantastic calf
stretch and so many of us have tight
hamstrings and tight calves which
impedes our movements whether we're
jumping or running which makes us stiff
and achy in the mornings particularly in
the lower back and which just robs us of
energy if you can't easily reach down
and touch the floor or kick above your
head then you're going to find that this
makes you feel generally stiffer you'll
recover more slowly from workouts and
you'll be much more likely to injure
yourself so finding a way to incorporate
this kind of stretch into your routine
without spending ages just in downward
dog doing nothing is a fantastic win at
the same time this is also a brilliant
stretch for your shoulders because in
that position you're going to be trying
to push your head and shoulders through
the arms keeping them nice and straight
and opening up the shoulders that way
improving your overhead mobility
therefore improving things like
handstand push-up military press etc
this is even going to build your
compressive strength as this should be
an active kind of stretch where you're
using your core and your hip flexors to
compress your own body a pike push-up of
course being an exercise that you can
use to build up to the handstand push-up
where you're diving down at a much
steeper angle and thereby putting the
emphasis on your deltoids you're getting
that same starting position with a nice
eccentric contraction thereby
strengthening those muscles as well then
of course you've got the pecs and the
core because you're keeping these all
nice and rigid and the triceps even more
so than regular push-up because your
hands are further back down and then
you're opening up the spine and here
comes that thoracic mobility this spine
mobility which can help you again to
avoid injury and stiffness and which at
the same time can improve lots of
different movements whether it's the
squat and you're trying to keep your
back nice and upright or whether it's an
overhead squat whether it's a backhand
spring or a bridge and at the same time
you've got a little forwards lean there
with straight arms so you're building
the same kind of straight arm strength
and shoulder strength that you would
need for something like the planche all
of this is in a gentle and controlled
way that you can do for relatively high
repetitions without a risk of injury so
what a fantastic exercise the hindu
push-up really is there are a few common
mistakes people make with a hindi
push-up and if you find that this
movement feels awkward or difficult then
you might be making some of them
yourself so i'm going to talk you
through it here whilst highlighting some
issues and things that people normally
get wrong so if you start out in a plank
position this is the best starting
position and you want to stack your
wrists underneath your shoulders that's
where things can often go wrong because
if you're too close forwards or too far
backwards then you're going to have a
weird pike it's going to be too narrow
and that's going to make it difficult
for you to move or it's going to be too
long and you're going to be too
stretched out so if you start from here
you should be in a good position then
you're going to try and put your bum up
as high as you can in the air get your
heels flat onto the ground if you can
keep your legs straight if you can then
you're going to dive through the middle
like so not touching the ground not
resting your waist on the floor so the
whole time you've got a contraction here
looking up with your shoulders and your
head now in front of your hands and your
arms locked out straight and you're
gonna hold this position for a moment
trying to feel the flexion in the spine
just below the shoulder blades if
possible because thoracic extension is
really what we want as opposed to lumbar
but obviously that's going to happen as
well and then you just
bring the butt back up straight back
into that downward dog position and like
i say when you're here try and keep the
back flat try and push your head through
your hands to open up the shoulders
nicely
do it in a controlled motion you also
want to make sure that your hands are
far enough apart to get your body
through
some other variations of the hindu
push-up include the mckenzie up here
what you're going to do is you're going
to lie yourself flat on the ground then
you're going to put your arms by your
side as they were before and then just
going to raise your upper body just
using the strength in your spine to lift
the upper portion of your back as much
as you can not to the point of
discomfort or you feel any kind of
twinging and not pushing off your hands
they're just there for balance you're
just going to use the strength of your
upper back so it's a lot like the
superman in that regard of course don't
let stuart mcgill hear you say any of
this but if you check my video on back
strength you'll know there are multiple
views on just how useful it is to extend
your spine like this
or alternatively if you don't really
want the strength component and you just
want the stretch component then what you
can do is you can break this down into
two different movements the downward dog
and then the cobra pose the downward dog
we've already talked about the cobra
pose is slightly different because what
you're going to do here is going to keep
your feet flat so toes pointing out but
you're still going to keep your hips off
of the ground they're not going to touch
the ground you're not resting at any
point and in fact you're going to push
through the hips in order to get a nice
stretch on and to engage some strength
there as well and you're just going to
hold that position with your back nicely
up again
the dive bomber is a movement where you
get into that position which looks very
much like the cobra and then you simply
reverse that position back up the way
you came so it looks almost as though
you've rewound the movement this
requires more coordination and it's a
little bit harder you've got more of a
push going back the other way so you
might want to build up to that one this
is another benefit of the hindu push-up
it's fantastic for coordination
you have your quadrilateral movements
where you're coordinating the left and
the right side of your body here you're
really coordinating the waist with the
shoulders and the spine all moving in
one fluid motion you've got to be aware
of all those things at once this is the
kind of thing that can translate to
better movement in martial arts in dance
and help you to learn skills more
quickly especially because you're
building that mobility at the same time
it also activates the vestibular system
because your head is swooping like this
it really wakes you up because the
brain's like what's going on there's a
lot of movement here and it needs to
coordinate itself and it needs to figure
out where you are in space it's a great
youtube channel where you can learn more
about this called original strength i
highly recommend checking it out and to
do this your brain is going to use
signals that come from your whole body
but particularly your neck where you
have a particularly high density of
muscle spindles these being sensors that
tell us about movement and about changes
in length and what you're going to do is
use that information coming from your
neck from these muscle spindles to
figure out where your head is in
relation to the rest of your body so
you've got the vestibular system in your
ears shaking around and moving about and
your body would think that you're
falling if it wasn't for the senses the
proprioception it's getting from the
rest of your body and particularly your
neck so it knows where your head is in
space compared with the rest of your
body so learning this is fantastic for
improving like your aerial mobility if
you're doing jumps and things and your
balance in general and a lot of us have
very stiff necks we all know that we
have the henched over texting position
neck so if you're stretching out the
neck and keeping it nice and loose then
again not only is this going to help you
to limber up and avoid stiffness and
injury and pain it's also going to
further improve your balance and your
vestibular control hey guys adam from
the future here and no the months
haven't been kind so another variation
is the hanuman dan or the hanuman hindu
push-up and hanuman being a indian god i
think i'm certainly not the person to be
asking about that but essentially what
we're going to do here is going to bring
one leg up step forwards and through
thereby getting a really nice stretch on
the hip flexors then you perform
push-ups in that position and also arch
and raise the back in a similar manner
so it looks something like this
[Music]
as you can see slightly less of a
sweeping motion but i've seen it done
with more of a sweeping motion and i
think it's really what you find useful
and comfortable
cool thing about this is it might look
familiar if you do animal flow it looks
like the front step and in a similar
manner you can combine it with things
like a kick through or all kinds of
other variations to create this kind of
amazing push-ups flow which is something
that i really like to do
i hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around that
helps me out immensely of course if you
want to see more like it then subscribe
and hit the bell button so you get
notifications and let me know in the
comments down below whether you use the
hindu push-up already whether this video
has convinced you to use it now and what
other movements you'd like to see me
highlight on this channel in future if
you want to find more exercises like
this and if you want to train in a way
that does more than just build strength
and aesthetics but also trains mobility
speed reflexes balance even brain
function then you might enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training which you can find in the
description down below i also have a
print book out called functional
training and beyond which is an
introduction to functional training as
it applies to the general population and
athletes either way thank you so much
for watching this one guys i appreciate
it so much and i'll see you next time
bye for now
[Music]